you
oh okay ready so it's good it may be
live now I'm not sure if they can hear
can you guys
can you hear us are you getting can are
you getting levels yes we are oh my
goodness okay it is the moon you know
what you know what that is that is the
super duper wolfy bloody something you
know what hi guys so this is Curtis you
gotta go follow me
I vote our instagram handles wait where
is it right somewhere right that's right
okay you guys this set up do we have is
so insane like it's actually great we
can turn it and show and just in case
anyone's like super super scared um
watch the screen here I guess I got a
drone just for fun for good measure
because you need a drone when you're
shooting a wolf
bloody a bloody wolf eclipse this is so
crazy so here we go oh my gosh
just so you know this actually was not
planned like we just happen to set this
all up in the past like 20 minutes and
it's working right there yeah it's gonna
be it's gonna be a good day so nice it's
a parent wait is it a bug in the moon
it's about this is so crazy
we're blowing it up so you guys keep
sending super chats so whatever you guys
are sending and donating we're gonna
donate it to to your charity yeah that'd
be awesome
that'd be so cool so all of the stuff
that you guys are donating what's your -
its Mogra orphanage it helps tons of
kids in the poorest slums in Nairobi
Kenya that's awesome well that's not
awesome but the fact that it incredible
charity but anything you donating
them yeah and not only that it gives
them a place to live because you know
they don't have a mom or dad or anyone
oh that's so sweet
I was like what people are donating is I
don't ever go live so this is super Chad
thing he's so foreign to me but that's
great
so anything guys donate it we'll be
going to a good cause so thank you so
much so crazy I can't believe this is
actually working alright so yeah so this
is I think for those of you who just
joined no are you this is my daughter
winter looking on youtube you always
want to be on YouTube yes so this is a
drone in the moon and yeah it's amazing
you know so we have a telescope here
this is I didn't show you okay careful
because do we not want to do that well
no let's let's show that let me see here
let me just let's do a little turn here
cool there's a lot going on this eclipse
is happening let me tweet them you turn
this on let me make sure this is let me
grab the link
this is gonna be so good maddie is also
here like I don't even know how to send
my link out because I don't ever
livestream how's the lighting oh yeah
good perfect
alright I'm taking a request what do you
want me to fly into the moon I can put
it below the drone this is cool
well I'm so hyped this is incredible
just moving some stuff around we're just
getting organized here so you're gonna
see me take some pictures as we go I
think maybe not here we go oh yeah
that's I'm not a Twitter Instagram er
okay I just want to know why she tagged
you um
okay I have a Twitter it's called
digital forces but I don't even worry
about
this is so cool all right this in other
news
okay so this is someone's butt this is
happening so I'm gonna tweet this out we
tweeted it alright so here we go I'm
gonna try to show what you want to do it
oh shoot I'm moving the moon I'm moving
the moon guys oh we better land that
drone it's about to die should I Maddie
where are you bud I don't want you cuz
they'll go after the drones because he
is crazy there it is there's that you're
on it that's so nice it's so crazy
holy moly okay so we want to show you
guys what this looks like
is there a buncha I can't hear use no no
I don't think so um okay so I'm gonna
turn this a little bit yep I should
probably also plug this in if we have an
outlet okay look at this look at this
setup oh my gosh you're so crazy like
this nut this is I mean this is like
NASA tuck it's kind of like that yeah so
this is a we usually use this for deep
space images you can see some of my ig
but yeah it's basically it's not even
that long of a focal length it's about
two thousand millimeters so we're just
only oh we're punched in on the moon we
got drones in the air you know it's
going it's going off this is and so we
set this up so we got a helicopter
coming
so the moon is
there's literally a helicopter like
flying at my
well I love to livestream using I didn't
see when you took off stars now it's
finally clearing up oh okay
Wow this is so great guys this is like
the coolest livestream ever that we
accidentally have done
[Music]
all right so back to it here we go so
this is a 2000 millimeter telescope or
zoomed in on the super wolf blood moon
yeah there's a bunch of coyotes howling
here let's be quiet like thirty coyotes
howling cool inside and we're just
taking shots you'll see them tomorrow
will post maybe tonight will posted
there we go look at that banging away
one after another I'm like babysitting
the dog but this thing is so insane how
long have you had this not very long
like maybe nine months it's like a baby
and now it's
this is so cool but you guys should
definitely check out his Instagram it's
up here it's seriously like the coolest
shot ever since you've been doing all
this Astro stuff like it's insane so
this I got this for deep space so we
have a like a bunch of deep space images
up there but pretty cool for the moon
and I can expose here just try to expose
for the dark part and just see if
anything's even there so you can see
down there you can actually see into the
dark part is it called the dark part I
don't think so a darker part of the
[Music]
here you can see the clouds kind of
ripping by here we go we have seven
thousand people watching that's good
there you go
hello friends welcome to the freaking
moon welcome to the movie little moon
one of my favorite things to do when I
should be doing other things is read
like moon conspiracies really yep
have you ever heard of the Pelagians oh
yeah so there's the palladiums
apparently what is that constellation
it's but the internet would know someone
tell us I believe it okay so I've got
the chat all popped out here so we can
actually see you guys chatting is there
actual lunar eclipse happening yes I
would hope so we could fake this every
day I could just like to put a little
piece of paper yeah it's super cloudy so
we decided to fake it so this is a photo
of the moon and then I'm doing this kind
of thing with that you know look at see
I can even so I'm gonna punch
[Music]
yeah hi guys
right now we are live streaming the
lunar eclipse this is Curtis go check
out his Instagram and check out this
insane rig the you have right here this
is so nuts but we're live-streaming
swipe up if you want to check it out
it's called my youtube channel Nettie
there you are there he is it's the Maddy
moon look at you can see so there's like
a little bit of a red kind of like I can
see it on my screen I don't know if you
guys can see it but there's a little bit
of a red kind of like haze above the
Eclipse line and then once again we can
kind of look into the okay so okay
alright this is so cool I'm so hyped
like I love the moon
we have got music
[Music]
so yeah if you guys know a band called
m83 vera and a another group called
cyrus reynolds they're here playing in
the background right here so it's kind
of
[Music]
just eat we'll be back in just a second
but if you could hear the music okay
tell me if you guys could hear that
music is it too loud
check out m83 they're playing live right
now hi guys
it's so cool
[Music]
I'm live - how cool is this everything
is live so many live live live live
there we go join mine - let's do let's
go live online - wait I'm on Instagram
right now we're doing it all every
platform look at cheese log
we got a MIDI 3 playing in the
background check it alright guys so we
got the hydrastine here is going live to
youtube check out i just stands youtube
if you want the full frame deal yeah
I don't know some of you guys like m83
sorry miss rennolds
[Music]
yeah we're all kind of running around
but if you want the behind-the-scenes
just run over to my Instagram Curtis
Morgan and sorry I'm doing like we got
Justine's here guys on my Instagram
we're running on her YouTube so go check
that out if you want like the full-frame
high-resolution stuff hey friends hello
it's our him oh boy this is so cool
you guys into the moon what's up
[Music]
just cruise over to I just I think
somebody donated $200 to us some awesome
African kids yeah this is incredible
99 a my seeing this and how much it
matters
that's so cool thank you guys so much
all going to charity so there you are
know it's a really serious issue that
they have over in Mathari Kenya so thank
you so much it's really amazing it like
makes me wanna cry meet you this is so
crazy
oh my goodness I never livestream this
is so so it's like foreign to me
[Music]
hello Veronica
Zoe happening I like it home I'm into it
[Music]
[Laughter]
the technical this is so bull
oh man the moon it it's eclipsing yeah
it is oh gosh this is so last minute we
seriously said this to others so quick
so this is the dark exposure cuz it's
that's the other side I don't know what
sides more interesting like do I have
enough battery it what am i this is so
crazy I think we're good thank you Alex
I appreciate it you're incredible you
guys are so amazing
what's up you guys think it's more
interesting here we got that side yeah I
think we'll switch over to this look
when it goes full looks so good what's
the deal incredible super wolf blood
moon and we've got dogs we've got NASA
great technology here this is so great
and if you guys think that this was
planned this was not planned I just
brought my laptop and some capture stuff
Dustin see it's we decided that this
might work and it worked
yep it worked Wow do it for more full
dark what do you mean you mean like
[Music]
oh my gosh I'm gonna make like the this
exclosure do it from our early we like
in the other side I feel like that looks
good okay
hi Maddie let's see how to everybody the
total eclipse of Maddie this is Maddie
djamena hat he is actually a DJ one day
[Music]
someone says they see red oh that's nice
yeah - listen seriously we did not plan
on doing this I don't
[Music]
okay I'm watching to make sure this is
okay this is so he's also taking
pictures someone said it's red someone
said notice me
can you say hi sorry nothing I gotta
jump back and forth a little bit for my
[Music]
oh great so I want to give some
shoutouts to people who have given some
super chats Jorge Diaz thank you so much
I appreciate it you said that you
inspired me to start your new channel
that you're amazing
although I got 50 bucks from Dan oh
thank you so much Dan I always see you
on Twitter so thank you so much for
always being so super supportive and
again this is great to do this for
charity
guilty crown oh my gosh first time on a
stream thank you on my channel go check
out Justine's YouTube it's amazing the
reason that the moon turns red is
because the atmosphere and I missed it
so the reasonings are gonna be a mystery
be careful don't look at the moon with
your eyes it's really red
[Music]
this is crazy oh my goodness
you can see the red from the other side
so where are you guys watching from
super Blood Wolf Moon set the hashtag
it's chilly I mean it's not actually
that cold but for me I'm weak so you
guys are just joining us this is the
super super blood moon eclipse of the
moon
this is an incredible setup this is
Curtis you can follow on instagram he
does some incredible drone shots also
some inci are you like the script tell
me tell me more
so his astrophotography stuff is so
crazy and this is the setup that he uses
he was telling you about it before we're
gonna have to give you like a quick
other little update like what is this
for the people that are just joining us
I mean this is a telescope deep space
telescope really specialized designed
for deep space but we put a sony a7r
three on the back so we can transmit to
your youtube here yeah and yeah it's
basically just like a 2,000 millimeter
lens with a camera but that's not it
because this is also connected to a PC
inside and you can basically tell it to
track stars you can tell it to track
and it does yeah yeah if you want we can
well it's kind of hard if you jump over
to my Instagram you can probably I'll
take you on a tour yes of the studio
where it's kind of happening on his
Instagram Curtis Morgan and then he's
inside he's going inside go check it out
thank you so much Nick thank you so much
sky domes is incredible right this is so
cool
[Music]
Wow
I don't know what else to say you guys
is like I mean it's here I feel like I
should I should probably move you guys
this way because if I move you over here
and then move the moon over here it'll
look like I'm looking at it what do you
guys think I hope that you guys enjoy my
new placement before should I put me
down here think you should put it in the
corner right here yeah yeah so now it
looks like oh this is so I'm so amused
and just you guys know like we honestly
did not plan on doing this at all this
was just a last-minute thing and it
worked
gosh this is so fun I love space
I'm running this actually off on the
surface laptop which is pretty
impressive I'm super impressed with this
setup
okay I'm gonna do a quick video under a
minute
talking about our setup okay cool right
now we're getting an eclipse of the moon
the super Blood Moon Wolf Moon whatever
it is it's happening because Curtis and
what is this setup that you have right
now what is this so this is a takahashi
fsq 106 telescope but it's essentially a
2000 millimeter telescope that yeah it's
[Music]
two thousand millimeter telescope we're
looking at the yeah so we have the sony
a7r 3 on here and you guys are getting
the scenes we're doing it again you'll
see this on Twitter in a second okay so
right now we are live streaming the
eclipse of the moon this is the moon
super blood whatever it is but check out
this incredible setup Curtis what do we
got going on here yes let's go Takahashi
fsq 106 and yeah it's a two thousand
millimeter telescope and so we're just
you know full-frame on the moon and we
got sony a7r three in the back taking
some 50 megapixel shots that's so crazy
and then I have this connected to the
Microsoft Surface book pro 2 and I just
had I actually just had the stuff in my
backpack and I was like should we try to
do this and we're now
but it's incredible so go check out his
Instagram people have some photos this
is happening and this is our chat these
are our lovely friends here's the live
stream and the moon it is happening like
it's it's almost eclipse Wow that was
under a minute that was under a minute
guys did you see that you'll see that on
Twitter shortly at the point where it's
like you kind of want to get yeah it's
like that's the good oh that's a hundred
oh my goodness take care I mean I care I
don't I mean I don't that looks so cool
space so we can punch in on it I think
it's good we you know you could go full
frame we could go whatever we can do
whatever I just you know what is the
hashtag is the question
super duper ultra
okay it's pretty sexy see how the clouds
kind of ripping by it's actually
visually kind of cloudy but this thing
pushes through a lot of that okay let's
do that
[Music]
what up stuff are we okay if you want to
know that stop we're at a five six five
six five eighty times for folks then
you'll know how many millimeters this
telescope is I didn't Siri five hundred
eighty millimeters times four let's do
the picnic Hey
five hundred thirty to twenty times for
Jerry
32:28 no man this is so cool this is so
awesome
yes it's so cool seriously again you
guys this is not planned but guys how
many people are watching some of us it's
two thousand five hundred and three
millimeters so they're doing the math
for me yeah no they're right that's
right that's exactly it
what was it again mm what oh shoot two
thousand five hundred and two it's going
too fast somebody tell me the math again
help now they're just saying about two
numbers are you guys into the moon or
what 2320 oh my gosh oh my guys this is
so fun I'm so into the Moon Moon but did
we the conspiracy is incredible
1:10 how is it even working actually
kind of hard to photograph I've never
photographed and they cool and if
anyone's just kind of like hopping in
here I just seen is on well I'm
transmitting to her YouTube so go to I
adjust Dean's YouTube and you uh yeah
you'll see it in like a little bit
better resolution this little phone
screen extension cable yeah there is
some way to get power yeah so you can
get power right here
it's a moon party
yeah so it's kind of hard to expose for
us on my is L five thousand and one
tenth of a second see I think we'll have
to go for there's a lot of technology
going on right now a lot hey what do you
think about some jamming just a little
bit of jamming just a little Spacey
we got smokey pickles if anyone wants to
know this is I'm like watching this on
the live stream but also with my realize
it's so great
thank you
yes oh we've got power Tata my screens
brighter this is so great
all right so it looks like we have
someone watching oh yeah they're so it's
like your people
kinda came over here this is Curtis he's
taking you outside I'm sorry inside oh
it's turning red it is this is great
daddy are you being a good boy
my dog's name is Maddie if you guys are
new here and don't even know who I am or
what's going on we've got also you might
not because this is a dog inside here no
I don't have a gross on my neck this is
a dog that's it Michael yeah Dale on the
trail he can't come out because he would
knock over that tell you probably would
hi Maddie
you look like a little a little moon man
Maddie you want to sit in my coat I'm
still two stops under six
so it's telescopes are fixed five six so
into the moon I realize Wow Wow
should you show them like stop down to
show them like what we actually see is
what we actually see right here sorry
guys I'm like so this is what we're
actually seeing right now yeah that's
about I'd say what our eyes are seeing
is probably about that
anyone want to come edit these pictures
for
[Music]
like it's just so cool
someone said I just notified you look at
it it looks amazing
someone give me a kiss at Blood Moon
[Music]
yeah the thing is wouldn't that be crazy
if it actually is flat and we're all
being trolled yeah am i flat earther now
whatever I need some drama I'm so boring
just sees a flat earther he knows I mean
we know it's not just for the record you
guys are wondering what those little
flashes are he's actually taking
pictures I was putting chapstick on I
give you guys some - I'm said marbles
says notice me is it red it is red it's
looking pretty red alright someone tell
me how high and a7r threes is oh if you
go before it breaks ah you know what
let's start the drama here we go
so I believe that the earth is flat I
mean it's like look at every picture I
mean I don't even know I can't even lie
to like I'm not I just can't even lie
let's make up enough reasons why I
believe it - you're at this flat it's
not don't be an idiot
guys make up some lies about what I can
say on reasons why I think that the
earth is have any suggestions on how to
make this thing not super noisy
raining not noisy as in the sound that
the camera is making it was like I think
there's a silent shooting this is still
crazy because like I told you guys
before if you're just joining me did not
plan on doing this
I brought my I'm actually streaming this
right now off of a Microsoft Surface pro
2 and I had it with me
I had my capture stuff and you have a
massive ridiculous NASA telescope and
you know why not we're like why not
let's try it I want to play like total
this is the heart but I'm afraid no I'm
worried that I'd probably get a
copyright strike and then it's what
everyone since then it's flat dude
everything is what you want it to be you
can live in your own live we have living
yeah wait that's right I mean what do
you think everybody does how do you
think we survive we just live our own
lives
wow this is so great I always kind of
battle with Sean says he's watching
right now on the stream and the picture
looks really good on the feet I'm like
waving at you like how are you I know
I'm pretty good actually
oh really yeah unfortunately someone
says the stream is logging on YouTube
and that's probably because there's like
700,000 now there's like 10,000 a laptop
when we look at my phone and see how
it's happening alright if anyone just
came into my deal just cruise over -
well it's - two stops because let me see
the flag it's dark it's extremely dark
it looks really good on stream look at
that Curtis tell Justine said hi well
what if what if I wanted as well I'm
glad I still have gloves in my pocket
and when I was back so who is watching
where are you guys watching from leave
us a comment and let us know where
you're watching oh wow look at it
I'm so are you yeah I try to find a
t-shirt but it was really not from hold
on this might screw it up guys so just
be prepared whoa really good good so
there's some video of the moon I don't
know if you're really supposed to be
doing one fifth of a second shutter on
video but whatever it's not moving here
we go should we do a little like pan
across it something because it's rolling
video let me turn off
okay
[Music]
so I got this little thing in my hand I
can kind of slowly control it a little
bit okay shoot because it is so it's
picking up audio from
see that below the level oh oh here it
is
okay how's that hello oh my gosh so
sorry is that better
is that better hello still echo the
audio changed is this if there's such a
lag so I can't actually not fix still an
echo
good so cuz they said that there's an
echo so I don't know what's that fix
some sus keep it centered okay Wow
so many things everyone wants thumbs up
and fixed good good now that's better
it's all back okay yeah looks great yes
if you're on mine go over to I just
Dean's YouTube I just need and we're
running my system out to I don't have it
so I put her this's Instagram right up
there if you guys want to go check it
out he's got so many amazing photos
someone's watching from Kentucky
everything is good in the audio thank
you
we're giving everyone such a great
experience I think so I'm having a
lovely it's a lot easier to be on the
East Coast so they can't not even good
boy he loves being outside he is loving
just running around
yeah that's pretty awesome someone said
I saw the solar eclipse in Wyoming Oh
total solar eclipse Wyoming that was
amazing
where to go oh god no you took the
picture okay holidays someone said it's
foggy where I'm at I'm so glad you can
see it I was worried earlier I mean it's
about as dark as it yeah
so awesome
someone says it's the middle of the day
in Australia well are you guys enjoying
it how is it over there as well they are
on the feed I get all these like little
love signs that sees the shutter stitch
okay I'm trying to watch your live chat
here it's going super quick so alright
guys I'll be back in a minute alright
thanks so much for tuning in
I mean that's that's the moon hello
Jesse they say that it is 6:00 p.m. in
New Zealand Denver 5:00 a.m. here in
England why is the chat so fast I don't
know
Germany do we see any UFOs well we
actually had a drone flying across the
moon earlier so that was pretty insane
yeah what do you think should we throw
the drone up there again that's probably
smart right does anyone think that's a
smart I think it's brilliant
Tiffany said I want to say things
oh yeah and for all the donations it's
really amazing and I just keep seeing
the little dollar signs roll in and it
just makes my heart so happy tell them
what the charity is again in case we get
again it's Mogra Star Academy you can
find them on Facebook you can find them
on a dot Mogra Star Academy org you can
find them on my site Tiffany Jade Morgan
that's my Instagram handle you can link
through it and little pickles pickles
even loves the charity but thank you
again
it really helps they they're in extreme
need of meals and library books and all
kinds of electronics so whatever like
basically what you guys did tonight was
supply a salary for over for all the
teachers for over a year my goodness and
meals breakfast and lunch for the
children for an entire year honestly so
thank you so much I had no idea then
people started donating I was like oh my
gosh we should donate to your charity it
really was amazing thank you guys you
guys are so amazing
go inside honey going live for this long
kind of takes endurance you know do you
know that I live streamed for six months
straight yeah six six months straight
you guys know twitch TV there was Justin
TV before that I stream for six months
that's 24/7 that's why I don't live
stream anymore it's good to be honest
with you that would like mm this is
really this is worth streaming this is
so great but I mean a lot of like the
gaming streamers they stream for like 12
hours and don't even that's like normal
how long have we been live I don't even
know Thank You Korina appreciated she's
live through my telescope on her YouTube
channel Wow raising money for your
charities there's a lot going on there's
so much so cool yeah you're mad at me
battery got a seven are three in the
back just backing clip take a couple
shots yeah so you can see it yeah
[Music]
Wow Wow telescope here live stream so
that thing you have a kind of cropped
out okay cool
just looking at this here we go oh yeah
see look I can move it over more
how's that
yeah that's good
it's probably smart if you fly around I
think so
I'm gonna okay undergrad back well I
want Maddie to go inside Maddie is
loving those who save a nice yard and he
is just enjoying it this looks so much
cooler right here
really so like how long does this last I
think it goes through like nine
suppose this how are you guys getting
internet because this is in your yard
steps from his place so internet is
super easy called this thing it's a
super new technology called Wi-Fi
[Music]
imeem should we stop streaming it now or
all right you guys wants to stop stream
t1o no one wants to stops yeah this is
amazing it's so cool okay
you look like it's hard to talk I mean
do you guys think it's in focus
some of us keep this room
okay well we're here we're here
I believe this is working
yeah that's about the extent of it
hmm some say they spill their hot cocoa
since that I've never seen a lunar
eclipse before Paul where's the dog I
don't okay so we can't know because then
it might get taken down some said it's
not in focus it seems it seems darker
than before that's cuz it's eclipse you
can barely see with your eyes right now
yeah so beside wait until eleven eleven
yeah I don't think so
well I think they mean nine eleven
twelve twelve a Eastern is your tality
so that's nine twelve here okay
keep the stream until the eclipse ends
okay we will jenna is not with me that's
my sister she has been very very sick
she actually has the flu and strep so
I've been staying away from her because
I don't want to get sick
so this is where are you we are in Los
Angeles the moon is turning red see I
think 9 12 totality we do 16 minutes
left
maybe try a see what happens in your
video
because I feel like the quality might
look better actually when you're doing
who do you guys think whoa look at that
yeah look at that well you could always
stop it to take pictures
[Music]
9,700 well we lost a few they must have
went to sleep you know looking at a red
moon all day especially it's not real
look it's these clouds are building yeah
but I think you might just make it
because we have like 12 minutes left why
did it happen tonight I don't it lasts
for an hour the whole eclipse should be
over by 2:00 in the morning oh okay
that's it's the Internet everything is
real since that I made a school project
then I just seen once oh my goodness
thank you I hope you got a good grade if
not don't blame me so this is a cold out
[Music]
I still got my East Coast gloves in my
pocket
they've also got touch so I can touch on
the screen Jenna is sick hello from
France hello John is praying for Jenna
thank you John I can't even see it yeah
I think we did it's going yeah do you
see it at all in there
yeah it's going away so if you don't see
it the clouds are kind of coming in so
we got super lucky so right now the
clouds have just moved in so there's a
really good chance that we've lost them
but the moon was here so if you're just
joining us you'll have to watch the VOD
says I wish that I could see where I
live but it's snowing hello
al Mar hello Madeline let it run should
we just let it run or we could just let
it run what do you guys think
because I don't see anything
well guys I think through the clouds
have moved in so don't think that we're
gonna do anything else
what do you think you just let it sit
and run for ten minutes if you want I
mean it might clear back up just the
pocket but it's not gonna be great yeah
huh
oh man guys I was so but I feel like
this is such an incredible stream and a
huge thing he took her putting this
together like I just came over with my
laptop thinking I might as well bring my
surface book see if this actually worked
because we did a drone livestream once
using the surface this is sponsored but
it's just so much easier to stream from
a PC most of the cool telescope set up
let's see what we could do and so did
everyone wants me to keep it running
[Music]
yeah
is there what I can't see it because not
only is it eclipse but the clouds just
moved in it's so crazy
so I think we might have to end this
dream now
cars trying to make mistakes we were all
this I've dinner we did not plan a live
stream we just land I'm watching the
moon cookie this is all so spontaneous
but I appreciate you guys hanging out
this was so much fun and again all of
your donations that you guys donating
tonight was all going to charity so I
appreciate it you were all incredible
thank you services where's the moon the
moon's eclipse - can't see it the clouds
have covered it cuz total see the
totality would have been is actually
well it's happening at 9:12 our time
maddie is having a great time that's my
dog he's just running around like crazy
we're just gonna give it a couple more
minutes because I just want to look I
see nothing right now at all it's gone
yeah so not only is it eclipsed but the
clouds moved in so yeah it's like
completely covered now and so was it you
supposed to get glasses for Eclipse yeah
you are but for the Sun it's dark out
this is the moon mmm
yeah thank you guys for watching this is
super cool should set up a spam limit a
spam limit I'm sorry I don't livestream
very much so you're gonna stay they can
see the total eclipse from Puerto Rico
please say my name hi Natalie
Zoe moon come back it's gone a very big
super tiny little bit of it through here
actually you can kind of see it can you
see it there's a little bit of it
there's a tiny bit turn up your
brightness can you see it like right to
the side
it is cold the connection is good
outside because we're basically in their
backyard
so there's internet guys I'm freezing
I'm cold
Maddy do you wanna come here say hi this
is my dog hello so now you definitely
give the animal room you can see like a
small little sliver of it
oh it's coming back it's coming back
Maddy
I've kind of see it with my real eyes I
mean I can't see it on here though
what's there is there yeah no you can
see it just like the edge of it yeah
very a little bit yeah can you guys see
it do you see the edge when is totality
it said like nine twelve so you might as
well just wait until then someone's
coming back
maddie is just like watching like what
is happening
this is like there's a lot of clouds
guys oh so sad but we got it we got a
lot of good stuff yeah sure
I can make this bigger now so I guess
let's show them one more time before we
leave like their crazy setup I'm gonna
make this not showing up because it's
behind clouds okay let's do this
since the moon is taking a timeout oh my
gosh we're fullscreen okay one more time
let's take them through this setup of
what you got going on here because it's
this is Kurt our Instagram is over here
he's got so much cool Astro photography
stuff but it's not just like Astro it's
like deep space deep deep space yeah so
I got into this actually somewhat
recently but this is just a telescope I
usually use a black-and-white camera on
it but we just through a Sony a7 on the
back of it 50 megapixel camera and a
little adapter here it's about two
thousand twenty one hundred millimeters
so it's crazy so this is basically
connected from the cameras streaming
into Microsoft Surface laptop and then
but inside there's also a PC that this
is hooked up to now what is that yeah so
it's running through a program called
Sky X and you essentially have an entire
map of the sky and you can click on any
object in the sky in real time and tell
the telescope to go there
and then it will track with that object
so that's what you know if you've been
on for a little bit that's what its
gonna do and just kind of holding that
trajectory the moon because it knows
where it is and then it's the mount here
is like offsetting slowly with the you
know with the movement of the earth and
compensating for that to kind of keep
looking at the moon so basically what
you just said is this
is moving automatically and tracking the
moon but the cool thing is you were
telling me before about the you do long
exposures on stars so this will track
and pinpoint one star and be off like
why yeah it'll stay on like you can stay
inside of a pixel the entire night
unless it's like super cloudy yeah
what's the longest you shot like for one
photo
so I've done like about a five night
photo so this stays outside just all
night like 30-minute exposures and mind
you like I don't not really what I do so
it's like this is like my night so crazy
you know it's just yeah it's a lot of
work but it's super rewarding yeah so
yeah this is super super cool
like I've been seeing you post all this
stuff online there I just couldn't
actually comprehend what you were doing
until I'm actually seeing it yeah I
researched it for like a couple years
and just kind of decided like you know
why not this is an insane rig no joke
I'm super impressed well the moon is
gone it's eclipsed and there's also
clouds so you guys can't actually see
this but this was a really cool
experience and such a cool experiment
next time yeah let's plant it next time
we're gonna plant it we had this
unplanned an unplanned live stream as
cos okay come over to check out the
telescope we're gonna maybe point out
the moon maybe we'll get something so
let's see it is 911 which would be 11:11
happy 11:11 everyone
9:12 would be totality so or no wait did
you think let's see yeah that would be
right I'm gonna I'm gonna pop you guys
down make this smaller and you can see
what we're not seeing because there's
nothing there anymore but the moon
should be right here where I'm putting
that text I swear it was there who isn't
watching the longest no hey Mattie come
here honey you bingo boy whoa we also
have music
so this should be officially totality
time guess what
can't see anything this is super cool
well thank you guys for joining us make
sure you follow cart follow me on
Instagram
subscribe my channel if you're not
already if you're new here I post a lot
of tech stuff Kirt also posts a lot of
astrophotography deep space a lot of
drone things she's got some crazy drone
rigs like it's it's crazy and I'm sorry
but it's super fun but yeah thanks for
joining this was super fun enjoyed the
livestream and thank you guys for all of
your donations again all of those
donations are going to charity so I
appreciate it you're all incredible just
know that it will be going to a good
cause so I think so you think do it now
that's it oh we are we done now
cuz I think that I think that we're done
do you want to say bye to them okay let
me let me put this back - to a full
screen
gosh I'm such a good livestreamer okay
thank you guys for joining us again this
is Kurt Instagram is over there yeah
sorry the clouds came in and it's we got
it though
throw up a couple of photos in just like
a minute here I'll give you a couple to
post to and so we should be able to post
something yeah for sure we'll keep it
going and if it goes if it comes back on
thank you thanks for watching go hold
Kurt go follow me subscribe whatever I
don't know it's like do I even know what
I'm doing
thanks for watching